[Music]
[Music]
yo
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside live
moods live the all-star starters
recently came out
they're announcing the reserves today
how do you feel about the lineups
yeah nothing really took me by too much
of a surprise with these starters i have
been seeing a lot of strong opinions
about andrew wiggins as an all-star
starter i know that one probably hits
too close to home for you there greg but
a lot of people disagree with him being
a starter in this spot i mean
you got to remember these all-star games
are about excitement they're about
aggression they're about competitiveness
so regardless of the numbers sometimes
you got to bring in the guys that are
going to give you a fun and entertaining
game and wiggins he must have been
listening to the hate because he sure
turned it up after he heard all the
opinions about him and he's been playing
some insane basketball i've been cashing
out on him left and right so i'm not mad
about it because i'm making money off of
his performances lately but a lot of
people had some opinions about him
a lot of people do have opinions but you
guys be easy oh my god two-way wigs i
would say arguably one of the best
two-way shooting guards in the game
so just put some respect on my man's
name
but with that being said liv
we're doing what we do every week we're
here giving away locks giving away
hoodies and jerseys so get in the
comments i need gifts i need emojis but
most importantly live we need
winners only please
you were you were still kind of late on
that
we gotta we gotta work on that it'll get
better it'll get better
it'll it'll it'll get better it'll get
better but i'm giving out a jersey right
now why not i'm in the comments i am in
the comments comments are jumping as
always
and i see fire fighter
man c says my man greg what up brother
you are walking away with a hoodie but i
also say i also see jack boy jack way
says
lakers money line sons money line wolves
money line let's be great tonight love
the energy love the parlay so therefore
you jackie boyd37 you are walking away
with a hoodie of your choice alright liv
it's tnt thursday which means we're
betting the three by two the question is
will there be two three-pointers in the
first three minutes of the game last
week the three by two cash once again
in the minnesota
golden state game here it is live it
wasn't two warriors it was actually two
timberwolves jaden mcdaniels and my man
the former warrior d loading from the
top
three by two has been cashing usually we
ask you which three by two is a lot but
today fanduel is whipping up something
very very special they're offering a
three by two par lay so we got the
phoenix suns taken on the atlanta hawks
and the los angeles lakers taking on
those los angeles clippers and it's
boosted up to plus 350. the question is
will there be two or more three pointers
made in the first three minutes in each
of these games i need everybody to get
in the comments and tell us if you think
they are hitting and if you are riding
with us live
talk to me
talk to the people
what are you thinking here
you know i'm not gonna lie this one is
gonna be a sweat okay this is not an
easy parlay that we're gonna be riding
with tonight both the clippers and the
suns ranked top five in perimeter
defense
i think defense is gonna be tight on
those sharp shooters early in the game
but with a value at plus 350 can you
really resist it i mean we love some
plus money they're boosting it for us
we're gonna be sweating it out no doubt
but what's wrong with a good sweat it's
not a good cash out if you didn't sweat
it out so we're gonna sweat this one out
but it'll be nice plus 350 you can't
resist
i like i like what you did right there
liv she says we're gonna be sweating it
out no doubt and i'm right there behind
you we are gonna be sweating it out but
i am in the comments right now
in the comments looking for lox uh i see
maxwell rexella in the comments shout
out to you he's rocking with the book
over tonight okay i got
goat garden saying let's go snoopy he
said i'll throw a dollar um
i'ma just give out a hoodie right here
i'm gonna just give out a hoodie to
anybody i see dale preet one deal freak
one
is saying no to the three by two but i'm
still showing love to you and giving you
a hoodie but guess what we are all
we are all we're going to use reverse
psychology here liv we got del plique
saying no to the 3x2 but guess what we
are all
riding the 3x2 parlay in del plete we
are sending you a hoodie for good vibes
but uh we're riding live and then if
you're at home if you're considering it
just ride with us but live we talked all
star starters earlier people think the
book got snubbed he's not starting this
year so today we asked you in the app
how many points will the book
make tonight how many points is he gonna
cook up tonight uh the line is currently
sitting at 29 and a half let's take a
look at the current odds liv do you
think the book is going to try to prove
the all-star voters wrong tonight
what point of prop do you like
of course he is i mean booker dropped 38
the last time that he played the hawk so
him scoring 30 plus would not surprise
me especially if he's motivated to prove
people wrong that is a guy i trust to do
that um but tonight i'm really liking
michael bridges in this spot in the last
seven the hawks have given up the eighth
most points almost 24 per game to
opposing small forwards not to mention
bridges has been on fire and he has hit
this over in the last three so i'm
loving this spot for him bridges over 13
and a half points i really like this
spot for him tonight i think he hits
this over so i'm rocking with mikelle
bridges
liv is rocking with mikael bridges uh
i'm gonna get to these comments i'm
going to get to these comments and then
i'm going to hop in with my pick uh my
boy mike b is in the comments michael
michael bowling is in the comments and
he's saying uh he loved all the parlays
cooking up
mad dodgers in the comments and booker's
scoring 36 shout out to you matt dodger
you were walking away with a hoodie
zeke the god says 30 to 35 for d book
love the vibes in the comments for my
mandy book
but no i don't want to focus on d book i
want to look at kevin hurt can we please
pull the graphic back up because i want
you guys to look at kevin
herter down there second to the bottom
over under sitting at 12 and a half hey
my man scored 26 in this last game liv
and um i heard trey young is
questionable tonight with the shoulder
injury so if he's playing and even if
he's not playing look for herder to be
getting up those shots tonight so i'm
rocking with him in the over liv uh gave
out the hoodies already so it's time
to talk major markets money lines
against the spreads and point totals for
tonight's game live let's take a look at
the odds what are you seeing here and
what do you like
yeah i got a ride with the suns tonight
to cover the spread the hawks rank
bottom six for total points allowed per
game and the sun's ranked top three in
points scored per game i like the suns
to cover that four the hawks are one and
three against the spread as a home
underdog and the suns are 15 and 8
against the spread on the road i think
the sun seam is just too good on both
sides of the ball to not cover against a
hawks team that has pretty weak defense
so give me phoenix minus four
lives rocking with phoenix minus four
live i actually like that let's pull
that graphic back up because last week i
cooked up a parlay live and it hit and
so i'm feeling the vibes of doing it
again i'm going to rock with the suns
and the on the road in this one i
mentioned trey young not playing maybe
playing it's uh up in the air but i
think the suns is the more complete team
out there in phoenix and then i also
also want you guys
to take a look at the sacramento kings
facing my yes my golden state warriors
take a look at the spread
usually the sacramento kings played the
warriors very very tough
and uh the spreads just too big for me
today so i'm gonna rock with the king's
spread parlayed with phoenix spread and
uh
we're gonna take this one to the bank uh
liv
it liv
let me go to the comments let me go to
the comments because i gotta give out
some hoodies um i was gonna ask you to
get in the comments live if you want you
can always jump in the comments pull out
the handy dandy phone pull up the
bleacher report app and get to it
because that's where they are i got jc
1030 says booker's dropping 39 tonight
on atlanta and will continue his hot
streak meanwhile cp3 will dish out 12
assists sons are gonna get the win hey
shout out to you you are walking away
with a hoodie i also have uh
i also have
jrb nice says holly burton eight plus
assist tonight okay i like that i like
the curve balls there hey everybody that
i mentioned you guys are walking away
with a hoodie hold on i have one more
live go big or go home sun's minus four
over 235 and golden states by 14 parlay
winners only appreciate the winners only
love right there you are walking away
with a hoodie uh
liv the comments are jumping the
comments are jumping but we talked major
markets now let's talk player props it's
time for lock or not i'm gonna put up a
prop and i need all of you everybody in
the comments to tell me whether
it's a lock
or it's not live are you ready to get
this started
let's get to it
let's get right to it first up is
anthony davis to have over 26 and a half
points
it's sitting that minus 114 lift talk to
me talk to the people do you think this
is a lock
or do you
not think it's a lot
i do think this is a lock in the last
seven the clippers have given up the
most points to opposing centers at 28
per game i love this play i think davis
who had 27 the last time that he played
the clippers and who has hit this over
in the last three will continue to score
in a very similar fashion tonight so
over 26 and a half lot for anthony davis
liv i'm right there with you i'm right
there with you just to name off
some of anthony davis recent point
totals we got 31 27 30
30 hat 30 last night my man's been
looking very assertive with no lebron
james
i think i'm gonna rock with you and take
the over in this one uh
i'm in the comments right now i'm in the
comments i want to see what they are
talking about uh domingo domingo 25 says
ad is a lot to go over 26 and a half so
shout out to you domingo you are walking
away with hoodie live next up we have
russell westbrook to record 10 or more
assists tonight it's sitting at -104
talk to me talk to the people is this
one a lock or not
yeah i do think this one is a lock i
like this play a lot this season he's
averaged 7.8 assists per game without
lebron james that number increases to
8.9 and with anthony davis that number
sits at 8.5 assists per game i think he
will be feeding the ball to davis all
night long and hitting this number in
the last two makes me think that him and
davis have kind of started to figure out
their groove they've found their
chemistry he knows he's in that
facilitator spot and anthony davis is
doing the scoring so he's feeding it to
davis all night long i think it's a lock
i love the play
liv it's funny it's funny we talked
about this before the show but i i don't
know me man you we're on the same
wavelengths i thought that you were
still in my notes before the show
because i literally have it written
right here in order for 80 to have a
good game and we mentioned ads gonna be
balling today him and westbrook they're
gonna have to connect a lot of pick and
rolls my guys westbrook is going to have
to be feeding a.d so i can see my guy
was we're going over 10 assists uh and
we also got to mention
no brawn
no brian so the ball can be on my guy
westbrook and a lot tonight uh so let me
go let me go to the comments let me go
to the comments
i'm in the comments and i see
phoenix1 says i'm feeding westbrook wow
those are opposite vibes of me and liv
but guess what you are walking away with
a hoodie phoenix one um
also i have bro holly bro holly says do
not lock that in
do not lock that in talking about
westbrook but liv you know what we do
here we we give love to where there's
there's hate or disagreement or or you
know confusion or whatever it is
whatever you may call it we give love to
that so both of you guys are walking
away with hoodies and finally finally
finally we have reggie jackson
three or more three-pointers tonight liv
it's sitting at plus
2 15.
talk to the people talk to me is this a
lock or not
i'm gonna say no however i do like
reggie jackson to have a big night
tonight he's facing a lakers team that
in the last seven has given up the third
most points to opposing point guards at
nearly 29 so i like the spot for reggie
jackson to do some scoring however
threes i'm not so sure one thing i do
know is he will take the shot regardless
so there's some hope there if you do
feel like sprinkling on this play
however this is a lakers team that has
pretty decent perimeter defense so i
don't love the threes play for him i do
think another great play though is
taking his point total over or taking
points plus assists because lakers have
been feeding
giving up a lot of assists as well to
the opposing point guards in the last
seven so i like reggie to have a big
night i'm not sure it's from the three
though so i'm gonna say it's not a lock
but
maybe his points or points plus assist
is worth your money
i'm right there with you uh
i don't think that this is the lock i
mean the odds makers don't think that
this is a lock either that's why it's at
plus
2
15 but liv but i would say my man reggie
jackson has hit this three out of his
last six games therefore making this
sprinkler ball i think that's the word
sprinkleable we can actually put some
type of money on this and and hope that
this hits but i'm not calling this one a
lot but it is reggie jackson i consider
him he does have that dog mentality and
he he puts up the shots he's a big shot
maker so this is sprinklable it is
sprinklable um
i'm in the comments right now i'm in the
comments seeing if they're agreeing with
the scene if they're going the other way
uh i see j buckets for three i say
reggie will get it might be close it's a
lock shout out to you j buckets for
three parker fritz says reggie is a lock
he is a sniper he's also giving us a lot
of fire emoji so shout out to you two
you are walking away with hoodies live
it is time to build the br betting
custom same game parlay which you can
ride with us on fanduel tonight we're
looking at the sun's hawks game and i
need everybody and i mean everybody to
get in the comments and tell me what
they think which legs are locks which
legs are not
let's get right to it first up we're
starting off with
the point god himself live
cp3
is he gonna score 15 or more points
tonight i think yes
liv talk to me talk to us nice do you
think yes
a little nervous about this one not
gonna lie uh you know i think he's gonna
do exactly what we need him to do in
order for devin booker to hit 30 plus
points and he's going to facilitate i
don't think scoring is going to be his
main priority tonight doesn't mean that
he won't get buckets but i think guys
like booker and bridges who are facing a
hawks team that doesn't defend small
forwards very well they're in a better
spot to me to be scoring than chris paul
is however
chris paul assists that's another story
and we'll get to that obviously but with
the points i'm a little nervous about it
obviously he can get him i don't deny
that he is talented enough to score 15
plus but i think in this spot i like
devin booker to be the guy and who's
gonna get devin booker the ball chris
paul so i like him in more of a
facilitating spot tonight but
it's possible you never know with chris
paul he brings the heat when he needs to
live
live
speaking of the wavelengths in the good
vibes you mentioned chris paul
facilitating tonight that's the next leg
of the parlay
chris paul to record 12 plus assists you
see how the dots are connecting here
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this part
of the parlay this leg of the parlor
i do i really like this i think he is
going to be in full facilitator mode
tonight feeding the ball to booker so
booker can cash on that 30 plus points
yes i think he will score 30 plus um so
yeah paul in this spot love him as a
facilitator love him hitting this assist
over this is a great leg
yes yes yes we are moving on with the
good vibes john collins to score 15 or
more points tonight liv
talk to me do you like this one or do
you not
well you mentioned it earlier we have a
questionable trae young and if there's
any guy on this hawks team that i would
trust uh just beneath trey young it
would be a guy like john collins i think
this is a good spot for him to step into
that leadership role if young is not
playing he is an aggressive player he is
competitive i think this is going to be
both of those things this entire game is
going to be aggressive and competitive
and john collins to me is that guy on
the hawks team to get the job done so i
love this i think he could honestly
score half of these points from the
three-throw line just driving it into
the basket drawing the foul because he
does play with that aggression that i
love to watch so john collins 15 plus i
do really like this especially with a
questionable young here
okay okay okay fill in the good juju now
let's move on to the final and last leg
we touched on this earlier in the show
you gave us
your side of this but i want you to
retouch this one and this is devin
booker to score 25 plus points do you
think my guy d book is gonna cash this
leg of the parlay
absolutely yes he has 38 the last time
that he played the hawks like you said
playing with a little chip on his
shoulder trying to prove the haters
wrong uh yes this is a great spot for
him to be scoring a lot so 25 plus for
booker
i don't want to say a lock but it feels
like a lock so i love this one yeah liv
likes it i like it let's put the ticket
up so we can see if we was to put a
hundred dollars down how much we will be
walking away there it is
522 dollars and 63 cents if you used to
put 100 down on this same game parlay
the odds are plus 5 22 live before i get
into these comments and the comments are
jumping what are you grading
this same game parlay
b-minus
i like it
i think it's a great parlay
chris paul scoring tonight is the only
one that i'm feeling a little bit
nervous about and if we do hear that at
the last second trae young is playing i
think that takes away a lot of
opportunities for collins to score so
you know welcome to the nba where
there's late scratches and game time
decisions and it just makes you sweat
your parlay out that much more but
what's not a good bet with a good sweat
so you know we're fine we're gonna rock
with it we're sweating it out b minus
you're still passing
the minus is the grade
live sam we gonna be putting that work
in tonight because we gonna be sweating
y'all get ready to sweat tonight uh
sweat these bets out i'm in the comments
right now i'm in the comments i'm giving
away hoodies and i'm also giving away a
jersey i got one harley senior jermaine
gave us a b they graded us a b shout out
to you one harley senior i'm actually
gonna cook you up with a jersey for your
grade because bees absolutely get
degrees and bees can get you on the
honor roll so shout out to you one
harley senior you're walking away with
the jersey
enderman is in the comments enderman is
in the comments giving us great great
insights listen to this one he says lock
it in cp3 will facilitate and score
today he's been he's been the fourth
quarter king and the point guard jc is
going to step up if trey is out tonight
d book is going to have at least 25
points
he has been going absolutely crazy
especially after feeling like he should
be an all-star
winners only please hashtag hey shout
out to you enterman that deserves a
jersey love the intake i got officially
ronald says greg i'm trying to win the
jersey today i bet it all he said i'll
bet on all of them lock it up all right
officially rhino sending you good vibes
and a jersey all right one more
nash2244 says bridges for 15 plus points
should be on instead i think liv touched
on my guy michael bridges so
i'm liking the connection right there
i'm liking the connection
rich you are walking away with a hoodie
okay liv let's talk futures the phoenix
songs are on 11th game win streak
and they're making a run at the west i
need you guys
to get in the comments and tell me if
you think the suns can overtake the
warriors now let's take a look at the
current odds to win the west liv your
nuggets are looking like a long shot
what do you think fiend oh but what do
you think of phoenix creeping up on
golden state
i think you know them creeping up in the
odds is rightfully so they're playing
very well right now um and that's
without a fully healthy team i know
we've had ayton and crowder kind of in
and out of games here and there uh the
suns are playing well and they deserve
to be sitting where they're at honestly
they could even be considered the
favorite and maybe should be considered
the favorite right now over the warriors
but i know you mentioned the nuggets and
they're great value but my cinderella
story my sleeper team this year is the
memphis grizzlies i cannot say it enough
this team is so talented they've got
guys like jj on the defensive side of
things they've got the big man in steven
adams desmond bain from the three john
moran arguably one of the most electric
and exciting point guards to watch right
now this team is stacked and even
without their best player in john moran
they were still winning games i love the
way they're playing i think they are a
hidden gem right now to grab them at
that value is incredible
forgive me for saying this it might be a
little bit of a hot take
but i could see the phoenix suns choking
in the playoffs yes i said it and i'm
sorry if you're a suns fan i think
they're great but i could see them
choking in the playoffs i'm really
liking the warriors and the grizzlies
the final two in the west battling it
out this grizzlies team to me is
definitely a sleeper team and worth the
money at plus 1300.
live i'll be honest i'll be honest if
i'm sprinkling the board on the west on
who's going to win the west
i'm right there behind you i'm taking
this memphis grizzlies team they've been
showing a lot of grit you mentioned jaw
went out they still showed that memphis
grit that that memphis mentality and and
still
captured wins
jaws back they're playing really well
they're worth the sprinkle i mean i
think it's plus 1300 they're worth the
sprinkle absolutely
but a team that
i've been rocking with since the
beginning
and i'm not faltering
and i'm going to continue to rock what
is the golden state warriors live they
took they took a bump in the road not
too long ago a couple weeks ago
everybody was wondering hey what's going
on with the warriors clay came back no
draymond everybody was trying to figure
out what's going on with the warriors
they calmed everybody down they starting
to win games hey they're still figuring
out clay just came back from a lengthy
lymphe absence they're figuring out how
to gel with another what one another
once again but once it once they get
that mold together once they get that
chemistry going
i think the sky's the limits for this
team draymond green's coming back james
wiseman supposedly supposed to be black
klay thompson
he's looking
kinda sorta like the clay of old but
he's getting back into game shape i
would say but uh look out for that
golden state warriors team do not count
them off
especially if the go if the los angeles
lakers continue to look how they're
looking right now that's the only team i
can see in the seven game series that
can give this golden state team trouble
so watch out for those lakers but live
right now i am in
the comments i'm in the comments giving
away
hoodies i'm giving away hoodies and i
see
i see ya yay says yay says warriors have
the easier remaining schedule sons of
the traffic once draymond gets back and
clay chemistry is over let me get a
jersey cuz
i can't give you a jersey cuz but i can
hook you up with a hoodie so uh shout
out to you you're walking away with
hoodie uh
liv i'm trying to get somebody okay here
we go domingo 25 says the suns have
playoff experience
so they can get back to where they were
last year shout out to you domingo that
also deserves of a hoodie because i feel
the same way uh dil preet is back he
says yes book is in his bag if curry
stays slumping
then the suns can take the west
uh
shout out to you deal preet that can
absolutely happen if curry slumps one
more live one more every player has a
big role that helps the team that's from
not steph curry
yes every player has a big role that
helps each team shout out to you thank
you for your take everybody that i
mentioned you're walking away with
hoodies live i'm about to take this
thing go home
thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today
the 3x2 parlay we are all riding it is a
lot get on fanduel to tell our br
betting same game parlay we'll be back
next thursday giving out hoodies giving
out more jerseys and more locks and
hopefully liv will be on time saying the
the winners only please phrase but we'll
see
but if you won a hoodie today
we'll dip you i'm greg ivory
alongside live moves we are leaving the
group chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
you